okay uh Diane HS the panel what is your
take on Pope Francis's anti stem cell
use policy anti stem cell oh he doesn't
want us to use stem cells you know he's
a good guy he's a good guy basically and
and I said this let's begun the show
everyone small he has got to kick it old
school
thanks to what he does he's like he came
out for exorcism yeah okay but that's
not that no one no one's gonna be mad
about that
yeah of exercise throw some red yeah
that's not a today no no you gotta throw
some red meat to the base you know what
I'm with up yeah well the stem cell does
affect people absolutely it's not gonna
stop it does he go yeah no no okay
seth rogen why does comedy touch less
nowadays on social and political issues
than it did in the 60s and 70s and of
course you are the perfect exactly hey
you're touching on social and you
weren't around in this i wasn't a lot of
it well I'll tell you uh I don't think
that's true at all uh yeah I don't think
yeah I know yeah I don't think that's
yeah yeah it I disagree with that
disagree with the perimeter actually on
that one bill I've interviewed a lot of
comedians in my show and won a lot of
them say is one of the reasons they
don't go there it's because they fear a
lot of them fear the protests they fear
not with social media and so a lot of
them say you know what if I can focus
just on family focus on things we have
in common versus something that could
really piss somebody off I mean a lot of
convene and say I'm gonna bother with
you it's what John Cleese and I were
talking about the crowd is too
politically correct I don't find that at
all it's really funny
yeah like waka Milan myself but like we
made a whole movie like it essentially
making fun of Christianity with this is
the end and while you're not there in
the theater right that's what's
different a movie is different movie is
then the stand-up act because a Chris
Rock says something uh in the New York
Times he said um he doesn't like now
because you don't wanna keep him working
on your material he said a joke may not
even be ready ready for public viewing
but I'm working on it
some money records it gets out and now I
gotta explain what the joke was and so
they say you know what I mean waste my
time but also I must say this is the end
which is a movie I truly love Brett what
a ghin what a nice really
I love the way it you know it kind of
looks like very loose yeah you know but
really obviously when you watch it the
second time like I did you see oh this
beat this beat this varies clever but it
didn't even strike me as that
anti-christian it's just crazy but I
think some people rapture and even most
Christians don't but I think some people
who get labeled as comics who are like
ooh the political correct community is
condemning me forget that they also have
to be funny and I felt it and I think
that when your [ __ ] is funny people are
much more willing to accept an idea that
they themselves might find horribly
offensive but when they're laughing at
it it makes it much more acceptable I
also think there's this new genre which
is you know you're one of the pioneers
of it built like you Jon Stewart Colbert
a lot of people get their news from
funny shows right and that's great but
not all funny shows challenge right
people to to face what you know maybe is
a prejudice of their own or just a
belief they want a hold that is not
necessarily true like Americans are
stupid anyway what does it mean
Christian that European leaders are now
turning on Putin it means that they have
seen the light it's really good
no I mean I think Putin is really
dangerous and Angela Merkel the
Chancellor of Germany who people thought
was kind of soft actually I think has a
very long vision and is standing firm
and it's a good thing I think it's what
Putin is doing is really dangerous well
yeah
but yeah I mean do you think he's really
gonna take over like Estonia I think he
could try I mean no no seriously like I
I think the two next things you could
see if we can try to do are either way
but is he going after Estonia now well I
mean the militia would be majestic yet
no no but bill is absolutely right like
no no he could hear you senior but I
mean even he could either sort of a
deeper in version of Ukraine which would
be full-on war war in the Baltic States
and it would be Estonia or Latvia
cuz there's mayhaps reach there exactly
they have regions which are 75 and 85
percent Russian right that border Russia
and what you do is the hybrid war
scenario you saw in Crimea
you don't like invade with tanks yeah
you send in agitators you pay local
people you disguise it as a local
separatist movement and then when those
local people vote for independence you
say to NATO so what are you gonna do now
are you gonna fight these people and if
Putin wins that Article five is over and
NATO is over and that's terrifying as
economies of the tank there's no growth
you know oil prices are dropping this
guy's not winning yeah
well he thinks he's winning because his
poll numbers are pretty good and you
think he looks like Daniel Craig like a
kind of slightly puffy Daniel Craig yeah
like a little more I think it means to
be gay I feel like a white Pootie Tang
myself white dick tank right merci
Chris Matthews you will get the last
question of the semester
do you think that Congress will be able
to pass any legislation that would ask a
good stuff right that would actually
help the middle clip middle you know
[ __ ] the middle class about helping the
poor
why did anybody ever ask about the poor
the middle class I'm sure they're doing
because the poor out as well but what
before have no lobbyists no because you
know you take the middle Clinton real
middle class somewhere you did 20 and 80
a year or something like that it's hard
to define it because everybody's more
class but you know basically they're not
every 3,600 bucks a year less than we're
making when Bush took office yeah in
2100 year 2100 dollars a year less in
real terms than when Obama took off they
are really getting squeezed there's a
fact no look at the most
getting squeezed because we keep
expanding the damn definition no no
Peter want making $200,000 a year or not
look at the people I'm some of the
people defined enough 71 percent of the
American people make less than 50 year I
know the real no yes that's the one well
out so I'm talking about another ones
getting squeezed and that's the story of
the economic life of the country right
now the average person who goes to work
in the morning does everything right is
getting screwed until you answer fact do
you suppose different it wasn't like
that in the post-war era this is a new
thing since the late 70s and that's why
people are really horrified too you're
like you do everything right and it's
not working in to Bill's point when one
person in that then loses their check
they go from that 50 down to 25 or 20
and now they're in that poor range and
our politician you're right it you drove
me crazy
watching these debates and everything
else is the middle class the middle
class because they don't want to accept
the reality and when we have one person
loses their job their whole life changes
okay thank you everybody thank you what
is it I pointed yes